I like this touch right and then he goes
around it I won't touch don't bang my
weapon but then a little pressure I
don't like and then he goes around is
here forward he goes boom is timing the
descent with my eyes up with my rear end
that's it
I'm waiting to feel the freedom
so there's tension now he's going to go
and I might get rid of their you this
weapon comes around the back my head
straight out reach out
Turner boom Turner and again not the
blade side boom reached over look here I
mean at full and I get a long on tap
wall-e sticks
I said whoa reach come on boom question
is context it is important but this is
the one this one is your ID and yejin
commencement okay now learn to make casa
Oh make contact
it's not it's like hollow hollow okay it
showing sweetie
Bigfoot better I remember and God said
that a picture elements yet is big bill
bottles this not Elvis okay I'm on my
heels on Bigfoot vector just like a spa
here wait here
oh it's a Tom then exercise so if you
put the stressor in your quads it's not
enrich on then still make quick no no
what the hell is that
okay same thing same thing
whoo oh he should be mid foot long I
come back
whoa mid foot mid foot no mid foot
hey hey like I want that tall us out it
reaches the touch then I'm gonna do Anna
Tosh in he's good absorber and he comes
again practices now and I gave in flush
and absorb it I'm going to hear that
sound
[Applause]
hey hey distance always East journalists
progression these trails of micro drill
is not the actual thing okay so he's
working on once he'll stick how to reach
out and touch the weapon how many child
touch the weapon don't imagine the other
guys doing this and we're fighting and
we stand like this because this is still
reach out and touch the weapon reach out
and touch the weapon reach out and touch
the weapon that says John he goes pull
okay my job is to do this duty here not
to pick it up to neutral go and get the
other foot leave it there this sword is
very light it's not the slope is you to
kill me goes down this side down this
side that's it go okay it's not
realistic but to feel the duty change
and blended I feel that you're gonna
feel boy
okay so again this is the fear body will
not let me take a kidney I want this
thing to stop coming at me so I get hurt
they didn't want to they are so the art
is about reconciling ready side
so let's look his sword is displacing
mine to my right and now therefore I
should not do anything that tell me my
sword stay up or try to move to the left
or maintain Center so if your aren't
going to maintain center go ahead boom
Here I am I'm going to stay up but so
sword goes this way I will not like this
or goes down oh you can see
I just had to let it happen
you're not leaving out okay so I dunno
if my hands will go from here to as low
as they can go
what if he's still pushing on me at that
point game lowering stay connected with
your eyes Keynesian he goes around pull
that's where your defenses don't fly off
the weapon here weapons going this way
that's what he's doing now I just make
sure my hands go down
[Music]
[Applause]
you